right over the weekend we learned that a
man who has coronavirus in fact attended
CPAC the one year I didn't attend oh
except I did go there to interview vice
president pence several Republican
lawmakers decided to self quarantine
apparently they might have had contact
with this patient congressman Doug
Collins is one of them he now joins us
live on the phone from his home he's
really not sick at all he's using this
as a vacation time no okay welcome back
congressman first of all I hope you're
feeling well I heard you are well I
wrote senator Cruz today he's doing well
mark meadows told me he's fine and we
certainly understand Matt Gaetz I don't
know he was wearing a gas mask last time
I saw him on Twitter but in all
seriousness I think we've got to be very
real with the American people I don't
like how we are scaring people
unnecessarily and that is that unless
you have a commune system that's
compromised and you are older and you
have other underlying health issues you
are not going to die ninety nine percent
from this virus correct that's great
John and it's good to be with you again
all right so that's the point I mean
with this hearing the living hell out of
people and I I see it again as like oh
let's bludgeon Trump with this new
cloaks yeah and I think what we're
looking at here there Shawn is something
that the American people need to talk
about that's why I said it myself and
others are following the guidelines that
the administration has put out and we're
making sure that people know that just
by coming in contact with someone
doesn't necessarily mean you get it it
also just it's about like keeping up
with a comment that you always had you
do the proper procedures you wash your
hands you stay away from people if
you're sick if you get sick go to the
doctor though the administration has
done a wonderful job if you need a test
the Trump administration is made sure
that doctors can give tests to those who
need them I've not had a test I'm past
the incubation period but we're willing
to make sure that when people follow the
rules when they follow what is out there
there's no need for panic there's no
need for what we're seeing and there
just needs to be a calm assertive mr. to
do what is right and things will and
this virus can be contained in the way
that it has it's going to still continue
to grow but we're gonna see it in ways
of fear and I think that's one of the
reasons why I'm going you know to talk
to you tonight and also say look I may
be healthy and that's what I'm going to
be and I'll be out of this yesterday you
know
the political side of this no president
ever acted faster he put in and by and
got criticized bike Biden by fake News
CNN why because in three weeks from the
date we identified the virus
he put a travel ban in effect and then
quarantine people hadn't done that in
decades and he still can't win with the
mob in the media or the Democratic Party
no it looks on we've been look I want
everything else you been I've been
talking about for years they're not
gonna will let him win on anything
because they don't like the man they
hate the fact that he's president hates
the fact the country's doing well and I
think even the other day we found out to
the CDC on the days of China actually
said they may have a new Cronus from the
CDC began to kick into action that day
so this false narrative that the
Democrats and the mainstream media are
kicking around out there is simply a way
unfortunately to try and get back at to
make some doubt in the minds of those
people this president's not doing his
job he's been doing his job from day one
and I think that's what we just need to
make people concentrate on because when
you concentrate on the truth and the
facts fear does not exist all right
Thank You congressman wait I can't wait
to have you back if you do have an
elderly family member that maybe has
gone through chemotherapy as a
compromised immune system in any way
underlying health issues take the extra
extra extra caution almost treat them
like quarantine be very careful we'll
all get through this together